good evening Rolanda welcome to Piers
Morgan and sense that it's the world
exclusive interview that's got the whole
world talking and have a vested interest
because I'm the one that did it days
before the football World Cup football's
biggest ever star has rocked the
sporting World we're running it they're
talking about it you can see the entire
interview interview to Piers Morgan just
breaking in England an exclusive
interview between Pierce Morgan and
Cristiano Ronaldo she's done this huge
high-profile interview it's now gone
outside of sport football media outside
of sports media and now is in mainstream
news reports Cristiano Ronaldo who has
said he is being betrayed by his Club
the 37 year old's comments were made
during an interview with Piers Morgan
for talktv Ronaldo releases the intro to
a interview he has with Pierce Morgan
you got on there on Twitter and you
tweeted Ronaldo I don't respect the
manager Ronaldo who uh missed today
because of illness uh but has also done
any uh an interview with Piers Morgan
Bill Cristiano Ronaldo has accused
Manchester United off between him in an
interview there has been a huge reaction
to this interview before it's even gone
to air
and here are some of the papers around
the world in fact from America we've had
Australia you've had uh of course all
around the UK Spain Italy I've had
messages on Twitter from everyone pretty
much uh because he is in the end he's
the biggest star that football's ever
seen Ronaldo has nearly half a billion
followers on Instagram think about that
he'll pass that total probably sometime
in the next week far ahead of any other
human being on the planet
you can see the entire interview we've
titled it 90 minutes for Cristiano
Ronaldo right here on Piers Morgan on
censored on Wednesday and Thursday night
it's a two-parter both shows starting at
eight o'clock it's one of the most
explosive interviews certainly that I've
ever done tens of millions of people
have already viewed the two short clips
we released last night and there are
more fireworks coming later this evening
because Ronaldo speaks people listen
it's not just in my view the greatest
footballer of all time he's a global
Mega star
he's of course highly paid too and he's
extremely commercially viable to any
club sales of his shirts at Manchester
United broke all records within 24 hours
of him going back
and after a year in which many people
including some of his ex-teammates have
blamed him for the decline at Manchester
United he simply decided he'd had enough
they're trying to force you out yes not
only the coach but the other two or
three guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you honestly I shouldn't say that I
don't know but listen I I don't care I'm
always people should listen the truth
yes I feel betrayed and I felt that some
people that don't want me here not only
this year but last year too
well already the interviews deeply
divided opinion uh amongst fans and
wider football supporters the club has
released a statement today saying it
will consider its response when the full
facts have been established which I take
to mean after they've watched the whole
interview but Ronaldo makes clear
throughout our conversation the Jersey
utmost respect for Manchester United's
history is a club and for its supporters
he's as frustrated about the stagnation
of the once biggest football team in the
world as they are that's why he's
speaking out because as he sees it the
club hasn't moved forward at all since
he left 13 years ago
I don't know what's going on but since
since the Sarah likes Ferguson left I
saw not evolution in the club the
progress was Zero
for example you have a interesting point
that how the club as Manchester United
after suck
um Ole they buy they bring sport
directive Ralph ragnik which is
something that nobody understands this
guy is not even a coach
a bigger club like Manchester United
bring sport directive surprise not only
me but all the worlds you know nothing
changed surprisingly natural only the
pool the jacuzzi even the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which is I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
which is his it surprised me a lot I
thought I will see different things
different as I mentioned before
technology infrastructure but
unfortunately we see many
things that I'm used to seeing when I
was
20 21 23 so surprised me a lot
I suppose a lot of people there are more
home trees where that came from and
sometimes let's be honest the truth can
hurt nothing was off limits in this
interview no tough questions were pulled
Ronaldo answers them all with a brutal
honesty very seldom seen from a start of
his Renown he also opens up about the
family tragedy which befell him earlier
this year in which his partner lost one
of the two twins that she was expecting
and he talks about the disrespective
fields that he's been shown by United's
manager Eric ten hark he talks about the
glazers United's unpopular American
owners and he talks honestly about
criticism of him by his former
colleagues in the old United dressing
room A lot's already been written and
said about this interview just based on
the small amount we've already revealed
a lot of it I have to say is
ill-informed bile a lot of it is just
plain fake news the only way you'll find
out what Ronaldo really says is by
watching the whole interview here on
Wednesday and Thursday and I think
you'll change a lot of people's minds
when they do
would you let me know is the former
professional footballer turned pundit
Graham's soonest and two football rights
at the Times Henry Winter well welcome
to both of you so Henry uh given that
I've just spent uh 10 minutes promoting
my interview with Cristiano Ronaldo uh I
think it's only fair to balance it out
by saying that you've written a very
excoriating column as is you'll want
sometimes when you disapprove of
something about this today you think
it's a big mistake by Cristiano to do
this why
well first congratulations it's a great
scoop here's hi Graham I think I'm just
reflecting the views of probably the
majority of Manchester United fans that
this legend of the game as you say
certainly one of the greatest probably
top five players of all time it's
slightly tarnishing his reputation in
terms of uh
in terms of how he's presented himself
and he really should have left in the
summer I think there from what I've read
so far and what I've heard and seen in
your Clips appears you know there's
there are elements of him making
pertinent points particularly about the
uh the lack of investment it seems in
parts of Carrington and Old Trafford as
well so those are important things that
he's saying there and here's the
Statesman of the game and he should be
listened to you so I think it's you know
it's an important interview but I just
think the timing of it coming the day
after Manchester United had a really
gutsy win at Fulham a young kid comes on
gun that shows the future of the club
and I just think talking to fans and I'm
sure ex-players will will Echo this is
that you have to respect the manager
he's and I think actually ten harg has
been pretty respectful because anyone
who's seen Ronaldo play this season he's
37 he's played I think 520 minutes in
the the Premier League one goal no
assist look he's been a fabulous player
for Manchester United Real Madrid and
clearly still with Portugal but he's not
the force that he was and ten Haag new
manager New Era okay
okay I'm soon as I just want to play a
clip to both of you which is a new clip
from the interview which I think may
just give a little bit more insight into
why Cristiano Ronaldo feels quite so
disrespected by people that are running
Manchester United right now and I'll
tell you the background to this is there
was a huge Fury as you know Henry about
him not coming back to Manchester United
in the pre-season when he should have
done a lot of speculation that it was to
do with him wanting to leave the club
and get away and everything else in fact
as he reveals to me in the interview it
was because his little daughter Bella
three months old at the time who had
survived this terrible tragedy in which
uh her twin brother had died she got
bronchitis so bad that she was in
hospital for a week and he felt Duty
bound as a father I'm sure we'd all
understand this to stay with her I want
to play the clip and then just see
whether this perhaps slightly changes
your mind let's watch the clip
you lost your baby son and now your baby
daughter's in hospital exactly and you
must have been absolutely directive of
and the president of uh Manchester
United and then
kind of that didn't believe
that something going wrong which is this
make me feel bad really yes I am yes I
didn't believe you
they believe you but in the same way
they are there and never be ever gonna
change
the health of my family
for a football never
now or
10 years
behind or forwards and it's something
that really hurt me because they doubt
of my words that I struggle especially
Bell and Jill we had one week in
hospital because the Bell have a big
problem
and I didn't go to the preseason because
of that because I didn't I didn't
was allowed to left my family if
something happened
to do it the Precision because I think
it wasn't not fair to left my family for
a preseason this is why I didn't go
now when he said that to me Henry I have
to say I was pretty shocked and
obviously I've not been able to put this
to Manchester United I don't know
exactly who he you know spoke to who
didn't believe him but the whole concept
that anyone a senior level at Manchester
United doubted Cristiano Ronaldo's word
about his three-month-old baby given
what had happened to his family three
months before I find pretty shocking
actually and it's unsurprising to me
that that led to the breakdown in the
relationship
there were clearly two narratives going
on in pre-season one of them as
Cristiano who is very emotionally
articulated there and anyone with any
children will absolutely empathize with
him and his support for his partner and
for his children and for his daughter I
think everyone totally understands that
and if Manchester United had not shown
him the the warmth the love that he was
expecting then you know clearly they
were wrong with that my experience of
Manchester United and the staff at
Carrington and Old Trafford football and
otherwise is that she's not a cold Club
it's actually pretty warm Club there's a
lot of good people there who will look
out for a player like Cristiano who
obviously many of them got to know when
he was a kid himself at uh 18. the other
Narrative of course was always the
debate about his future and whether he
should actually continue with a manager
like ten harks so I think really he
should have gone in the summer anyway
but clearly everyone has sympathy for
you know the family predicament he had
at the time okay let me bring Graham in
Graeme you've been a one of the great
players this country has ever seen a
terrific manager as well you've been on
both sides of of this fence and I
listened to you this morning on
talksport very interesting stories you
were telling about your time at
Liverpool and when similar things had
happened to you and how you reacted and
felt what do you make of of all this
what's Cristiano Ronaldo entitled to
come out and have this say in this
interview with me well that Revelation
that we've just we've just watched
United will come out and deny it they
have to they're not shown compassion
that are such a terrible time for not
believing him Ronaldo's daughter was in
hospital they have to come out and deny
that I mean my take on that whenever I
was
um managing I will leave entirely up to
the individual if
if they were having if their family were
having a baby if he's if their wives
were having a baby
um so I'll leave it until you take as
much time as you need or if there's an
illness in the family take as much time
as you do we'll see when when we see you
so I'm sure United will come out tonight
that they will have another side to that
story
um I I get Ronaldo's argument I am
I think as much as people think they
shouldn't cut on some slack Ronaldo's
are standing in the game which is quite
unique there is he the best player
there's been there's a real argument for
him I mean I personally think it's him
or Miss in his stats would suggested
seven in fact he's done it in different
leagues would um goodness favor as well
um but there's no doubt about it he can
sit in the room with anyone that's ever
played football and said you know what I
think the best that's ever played and
there's a real argument does that give
you no no it doesn't I know what you're
going to say does it give you any
special entitlement I think it has to I
think it has to I think Ronaldo still
have some he still has so much to offer
not just in the playing stairs but what
it gives you in the dressing room I
consistently say appears that you have
no chance of being successful unless you
have good senior Pros right he's a
consummate yeah
I sat with him for nearly two hours he's
still got this hunger burning inside him
to win more big trophies to break more
records to be more successful and what
he really craves is an environment
around him that can enable all that to
happen and he feels he just hasn't got
that at United and a lot of it he said
is down to poor structure and management
of the club that is spot on I mean this
is not whenever I talk about United the
United supporters are up in arms what do
you expect from someone who played in
Manny's Liverpool but I think United
have been mismanaged to further up the
tree I think they've consistently got
the football decisions wrong and that's
why they find themselves in this dilemma
I think um getting back to Ronaldo I
think Ronaldo
when he came along I was all for it and
when he came back yeah when he came back
I mean
there was nobody in that dressing room
there was nobody in that dress room the
younger players would look up to and say
I want to be like him in 10 years time
he was a he was the ultimate Pro you
could have gotten to correct that 18
goals last year in the Premier League I
think it was that one more one more than
Harry K yeah that that in itself so you
he is that good that special you come up
with a system to suit him what I believe
this happened this is my belief and so
without venturing into what we just
witnessed with with the you know these
tragedies and the baby line and the
another baby becoming ill
um that you'd have to come some slack
but I'm sure there's
United will have a different story but I
believe when he says
he wants to leave there was a meeting at
the start of the Season there's a
meeting would have taken place between
the manager and Cristiano after that
meeting they both left the room with an
understanding that's going to work
United start the season losing to
Brighton and then losing to Brentford
badly I think at that moment I think the
manager and the coaching staff thought
we cannot
go down the road of using Ronaldo there
was a feeling that maybe he couldn't do
the hard yards so from that point on I
think Cristiano
would have realized that he's been
around the block many many times
um so basically Ronaldo will feel right
now that he's been told a story someone
is not not kept her word which is a
manager
and I don't know if you've ever had a
moment I I had a moment rather famously
last year did when I had a little
falling out with my employers and I felt
I was being disrespected by people I
work with and I did this
and I to be honest don't regret doing
that at all
um so I kind of get uh let me go back to
Henry for a moment I kind of get that if
you feel if you're Ronaldo one of the
great players to ever play the game and
you feel disrespected professionally in
terms of what is happening on the pitch
and the way you're being used being
benched being dropped being publicly
scolded you know the mixed messaging of
uh ten Hogg not bringing him on against
Manchester City when they've got a
thumping and saying he did it out of
respect for Ronaldo and then literally a
week later trying to bring him on with
three minutes left when they're winning
tuna against Tottenham apparently
showing the complete opposite attitude
if you if you feel there's been this
build up of all this kind of
disrespectful stuff towards you and you
have in the background this awful
personal stuff going on as well and you
feel that the club has even doubted your
word about some of that I can see how
we've reached this point where he feels
enough and has come out all guns blazing
the truth in football is always out
there on the pitch and Graham as a
former manager and a former player and
he makes a very pertinent point that ten
Hart the new coach clearly felt that
Ronaldo couldn't put in to use Graham's
for he's very apt phrase he couldn't
pull in the hard yards on the pitch and
the Premier League particularly is such
a grueling assignment now it's just all
about stamina it's all about pressing
and with respect to one of the greatest
players who's ever played Ronaldo at 37
wasn't going to be doing the the
pressing that was required he's
obviously he's clearly a superior player
to rashford but rashford would run
himself into the ground for the team so
I think that there are other issues
there I think not coming off the bench
when he was asked to I mean Graham's
been in the dressing room I don't know
how Graham would have reacted if any of
his Liverpool players have refused to
come off the bench and then going down
the tunnel and this element that it's
all about me will in fact well he does
he does say to me yeah look he does
absolutely embodied in his Liverpool
teams that it's all about it should all
be about the team yeah I know I just
think Ronaldo's about the team but I
think and also the fact that yeah I do
think Ronaldo he believes his own
personal goals and Excellence as a
footballer helps the team he thinks the
two go hand in hand he did say to me he
did apologize to all his teammates and
shouldn't have done what he did at
Tottenham but he also Graham he also
said that he just felt this ongoing
disrespect from his coach both about
personal stuff and professional and he
just said it just it boiled over I think
it's down to him not him changing his
mind from the two this is what I believe
the two losses Brentford and Brighton
and then at that point he has to sit
down with him again and say look this is
what I'm thinking I think it just boils
down and it's to his credit that Ronaldo
wants to play every minute of every game
right he still sees himself as a winner
he he will be a realist as well he'll
realize he can't do the running down the
channels yes in the interview he's not
the player he was but he thinks he's a
smarter player than he used to and Henry
memory references Russian there's no
comparison you know because your stats
say that you're on whatever kilometers
or how how many miles it's it's the end
product the hardest thing in football is
to score goals it does that better than
anyone that United has I mean I I if
I've been managing them I I think you
have to come up with a United are not in
a place right now where
they want to be that's the politest
thing I can see well they're fifth in
the league the 13 points off the top
they're in the playoffs for the Europa
League I mean this is not a place United
uh used to be take take 18 goals out of
United Seasons last year it could have
been in the relegations where did they
finish yeah there are still there is
still room for United sorry for Ronaldo
United and and I think this whole Saga
has been it's it's been handled so badly
it was it was avoidable
um I think with better communication
with people telling the truth and and I
think that's where Ronaldo's beef is I
think he's been told in untruth can you
stay there now I don't think he can I
think all the bridges are burnt now
Henry is there any way back for
Cristiano even if you wanted to come
back
no chance and particularly the timing of
your your very good interview peers the
timing of it shortly after the final
Premier League game in the first half of
the Season there's no Ray Ronaldo could
have your interview could have gone out
a week ago because if he'd had to step
out in front of the Manchester United
fans fans who for so many years sang
Viva Ronaldo he would have very sadly
have got a different reception
Portugal had a good run in the hotel
fans right but if Portugal have a good
run in the World Cup they've got a good
team and Ronaldo starts banging in goals
in the World Cup I mean in the end great
players hold a lot of fun fantastic you
see we're upset fantastic but he's 37
he's not the player he was
still got a lot to offer Henry you know
if you go back to Aguero City where he
would be deemed to have been the best
during the hard yards the closing down
The Unwanted stuff Strikers don't really
enjoy it
he would get away with it you United
should have looked at the situation but
Manchester United have got a new manager
and a new era and ten hog was always
going to be Manchester United
now that it was very much their past and
he should have gone in the summer we're
obsessed this whole situation has been
handed handled very badly by United my
opinion he is a player issue kept on
site he is
a player that's something that you're
still us
I think I'll have a lot to offer a
football club for me they've just
they've handled it very poorly how do
you how do you how do you think it was
going to end when you're upsetting a
player of a standing I think that's the
problem we're talking about this instead
of United on the front foot moving
forward winning a difficult game I also
think I also think to be fair to
Cristiano that you've got to watch the
whole interview all all people have seen
so far are a few Clips literally there's
like two or three Clips it's it's a long
90 minute plus interview we're going to
air over two days if you watch it all
and you come to the same conclusion
Henry has fair enough uh but I think a
lot more people will feel sympathetic
towards Ronaldo by the end of it than
they might be feeling at the moment I
gotta leave it there Henry thank you
very much indeed for joining us Graham
great to have you on the show pleasure
for coming in really appreciate it